>>Teacher: So, one, two, three, go.
>>Narrator: Whether
they are learning how
to teach a first grade
science lesson..
>>Student: One, two, three.
>>Narrator: Or how to save a life,
students at South Grand Prairie
High School, near Arlington, Texas,
are pursuing their passions.
>>Shawnda: BP is 130 over 70.
>>Narrator: As sophomores,
students can choose to enroll in one
of five academies that will
prepare them for college and careers
in everything from accounting to art,
from building bridges,
to building arguments.
>>Student: He spots these two,
and with this jealous rage
consuming him, he murders them.
>>Roy: What we found out is that we
weren't successful with 60 percent
of the students, that yes, they were
graduating, yes, they were moving
on to life after high
school, but not at the level
that we would like to see them.
So we decided that old phrase,
what's good for one is good for all,
and go to wall-to-wall academies
for all 2,500 students, to give each
and every one of them an opportunity
to explore, to experiment,
to find out what they wanted to do,
and yes, to find out, what, perhaps,
they didn't want to do
after they graduated.
>>Debra: When we first
went to academies,
we were really fighting
the concept that moving
to career academies was
dumbing down and just catering
to vocational skills, and that
we were throwing academic rigor
out the window.
And that's not it at all.
>>Teacher: Where is your
roadway going to be?
>>Student: Right here at the top.
>>Debra: What we're trying to do is,
we're trying to give our
students some marketable skills,
either in their career,
or skills on a high level,
that they can use in the workplace.
So perhaps, instead of flipping
burgers to earn some college money,
they are repairing computers.
>>Stephanie: It's great being in the
academy, because you get to learn
with the people that want
to do the same thing, like,
being in big school, people
may distract the class,
and or not wanting to be there,
but when you're in academy,
everyone wants to be in that academy,
and you're able to learn more.
>>Chuck: Hi, guys, what have we got?
>>Shawnda: We've got
an 18 year old female,
her initial BP was 130
over 70, pulse is 64--
>>Narrator: Most of the
academies invite professionals,
like flight paramedic Chuck
Skinner, to volunteer as mentors.
>>Student: INO times
three at that point,
and respirations were still 18.
>>Chuck: Rather than this pie
in the sky kind of education,
where we all hold hands, sing
Kumbaya, and read Socrates,
we actually are talking about
stuff that matters today.
I mean, they'll come out of
school ready to go to work.
We have jobs waiting
for some of these guys.
>>Narrator: If they do well in the
course, and pass a battery of tests,
students can graduate as certified
emergency medical technicians.
>>Shawnda: And being able
to know what I'm doing
and actually take charge and do
it, it really makes me happy,
because if you think about it, that's
a real patient, you saved their life.
I mean, you were part of that,
you got to save their life,
if, of course, they live.
But I mean, you help them,
and you get to help them
and it's just-- it's so much fun.
>>Barbara: The formalwear that
you just started, I like this,
but we always want to include
some type of background, so--
>>Narrator: While students in
the arts academy are given time
to experiment and express
themselves, the focus,
as with the other academies,
is on pursuing a career.
>>Barbara: Students are working
toward pulling together their very
best talents and skills,
and take art very seriously.
>>Student: I kind of would
like to maybe do swimwear.
>>Barbara: By their senior year, they
are able to walk out of high school
with a completed portfolio, and able
to possibly get college
credit from that portfolio.
They actually are not just doing
class work and projects just
to get a grade, they are doing it
for higher purpose, they are doing it
for something that will
affect their future.
>>Tuyet: I see other schools
that don't have the AP Program,
and I really feel sorry for
them, because I'm getting, like,
a lot of experience, getting
chances to win a lot of contests,
and get my name out, and I
definitely want to pursue, you know,
art as a career, so I think
it's a great opportunity.
>>Debra: We are trying to create a
positive atmosphere for our students
and for our teachers, by
letting them explore things
that they're interested in,
letting them be with people
that are exploring similar things,
so they have the same kind of likes
and dislikes, and the
same directions,
and that makes them happier.
>>Student: Can you
wiggle your fingers?
Good job.
>>Roy: What I see many
times from students,
is that they truly have
that sense of belonging.
It provides an individual an
opportunity and a reason and a desire
to come to South Grand
Prairie High School.
I think that we are a very diverse
school here, and everyone fits in,
and I guess that's
what's exciting to see,
that everyone can,
and they do succeed.
>>Teacher: So we're
going to try again.
>>Narrator: Success at South
Grand Prairie High School,
often leads directly to a job.
In a unique program
called, Ready, Set, Teach,
the district has been able to
grow its own future teachers.
>>Ann: Ready, Set, Teach is a
practical hands on experience
and in some ways, it's-- would be
like the student teaching
at a college level.
We cover a lot of different
things, the philosophy of education,
different management
techniques in the classroom.
>>And you don't have to
always know the answer.
You can say, I don't know, but what?
And let's find out together.
Oh, move to the head of the class.
>>Jacquelyn: First I got
into psychology, and I did--
I even did AP Psychology,
and then I was like, oh,
I don't want to do that, so I was
like, well there's Ready, Set, Teach.
>>Narrator: After spending their
first six weeks in course study,
students like, Jacqui Gonzalez get to
test their newfound teaching skills
in the crucible of a
first grade classroom.
>>Jacquelyn: You have to have
a lot of patience with them.
I think that's the
most difficult thing.
You have to be really patient,
because there's like, 20 of them,
and they all want to talk at
the same time, and I want to go
to the bathroom, and you
have to be really patient.
I think that's the most
difficult thing about it.
>>Need you all to listen.
The next thing-- we need the paper,
because I don't know
what the next step is.
>>Usually when I tell people, ooh,
this is what I do, they're, what?
You're doing that in high school,
and you're not even in college yet?
>>The spoon that has
one fourth, uno cuarto.
>>I guess some people in
college don't even get to be
with the students as much as
I am with them during the day.
>>Narrator: After successfully
completing the course,
and getting letters of recommendation
from the teachers they work with,
students are eligible to receive a
letter of intent from the district,
offering a first job in
their teaching career.
>>Jacquelyn: What did
you all just smell?
>>Student: Yukky.
>>Jacquelyn: It stunk, right, and
what about-- what did you all hear?
>>Student: It was like a S-S-S..
>>Jacquelyn: It was sizzling, right?
>>Kristin: I was really pleased
to hear Jacqui vocalize, "Wow,
I was really glad when this
student had this response.
He really got it."
She went through a lot of the
ah-has, and the feelings of success
that one goes through
when one begins to teach.
>>Jacquelyn: Watch again.
>>All: [Laughing].
>>Kristin: And it's wonderful if
they can have those experiences,
because of opportunities
they had in high school.
>>Jacquelyn: No, high, real high.
>>All: [Cheering].
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.